le 9 décembre 2021 a été le plus grand
jour de ma vie à 30 ans je suis
officiellement devenu docteur en
mathématiques mais comment fait-on pour
en arriver à bac + 8 est-ce que c'était
si difficile que ça vous nous demandez
probablement à quoi peut ressembler la
vie d'un chercheur dans une matière
aussi obscur que les mathématiques où
tout semble avoir été découvert et
pourtant je vous raconte mon aventure
pas sûr que ça va créer des vocations à
quoi ressemble l'emploi du temps d'un
docteur en mathématiques voilà six
heures d'enseignement dans la semaine et
tous à charger sur le jeu dit [ __ ] du
cloud prof à l'université c'est juste se
la couler douce conservera qu'une seule
fois le salut pas vraiment je vous
apprends rien il faut préparer les cours
et ça prend beaucoup de temps surtout
quand on débute ça vous paraît dur de
résoudre certains exo imaginer le
sadisme qu'il a fallu pour les faire bon
vous allez me dire qu'après dix ans de
carrière j'ai juste à changer la date
sur mes pores poynt ressortir les télés
que je connais maintenant par coeur et
c'est reparti pour une année certes mais
c'est pas aussi facile vous oubliez la
partie submergée de l'iceberg le coeur
du métier du docteur en mathématiques la
recherche les cours c'est que du bonus
alors en mathématiques on recherche quoi
ya pas d'éprouvettes que des tableaux
remplis d'équations on se demande bien
ce qu'on pourrait encore révolutionner
dans les maths c'est bon un plus un
égale 2 y'a plus rien à voir détrompez
vous la recherche en mathématiques peut
servir à résoudre des problèmes
extrêmement concret comment ne pas faire
dire n'importe quoi aux sondages
présidentiels quelle logique suit le
cours de la bourse peut-on prévoir la
météo de manière infaillible quels sont
les chiffres pertinents pour suivre la
crise sanitaire si vous arrivez à mettre
parfaitement en équation les mouvements
de choses infiniment petit comme des
atomes d'hélium dans le vide alors vous
pouvez prévoir le mouvement de quantité
beaucoup plus grande de ce gaz comme les
gars l'ex voilà ce qui est un
mathématicien un architecte d'outils
pour mieux comprendre le monde qui
t'entoure et moi je me suis spécialisé
dans les onglets et les fractales ça
veut dire que je prends des signaux
comme ton rythme cardiaque ou la
température d'un volcan et je les
analyse grâce au spectre fractales pour
mieux les comprendre et anticiper les
problèmes il existe un troisième rôle
méconnu du docteur à l'université
enseigner recherché est instituée par ce
qu'on appelle la re lecture par les
pairs c'est ce qui fait que tu aies
recherche sont validées ou non n'importe
qui pourrait écrire une thèse dans son
coin mais ça n'aurait aucune valeur pour
qu'elle soit reconnue tu dois convaincre
d'autres docteurs que ton travail tient
la route et ils sont sans pitié le but
est de démonter la théorie par tous les
moyens et c'est pas parce que ce sont
des vieux grincheux
je ils ont trifouillé le moindre détail
pinailler sur une simple virgules c'est
de bonne guerre eux aussi sont passés
par là c'est grâce à ça que les
mathématiques sont aussi précise c'est
un travail d'équipé inter
générationnelle c'est pour ça que les
chercheurs voyage beaucoup on nous fait
régulièrement intervenir dans pleins
d'université différentes de marseille
jusqu'en belgique pour rencontrer les
équipes et leurs idées nouvelles
discutez suivre des exposés partager et
s'imprégner de nouvelles idées c'est
ultra cool on voyage partout le
quatrième et dernier rôle qui incombe
les chercheurs c'est le service à la
collectivité
je dois faire naître des vocations pour
les mathématiques représenter mon
université ou un pays à l'international
c'est pour ça que je fais de la
vulgarisation scientifique sur cette
chaîne et que je m'occupe de
l'association animat soutenu par l'état
du coup à mon emploi du temps du début
il faut ajouter mes recherches mais
relecture par les pairs mes activités à
la collectivité et tout d'un coup c'est
beaucoup plus rempli que six heures de
cours on est même très loin des 35
heures je vais pas m'en plaindre il n'y
a pas plus grandes chances que de faire
un métier de passion alors comment
obtenir le bac + 8 dans la scolarité
européenne on a trois grades licence 3
ans et des cours normaux master 2 ans
des cours normaux plus un ou deux
mémoires à rendre en fin d'année cd mini
thèse format réduit mais aussi celui à
traiter de l'exposition coloniale de
lyon en 1914 et des enquêtes de police
pendant la première guerre mondiale le
plus difficile à ce stade c'est de
trouver un directeur condition
sinequanone pour passer au niveau
supérieur ouais c'est déjà la cour des
grands ce n'est plus des parcours
automatisé comme à l'école et vous
imaginez qu'au moment de passer en
doctorat c'est encore pire déjà il faut
réfléchir au sujet et croyez moi c'est
pas facile surtout comme moi qui demande
à mes directeurs un sujet où il ya un
peu tout et pourtant ils ont réussi
laissez moi vous donner l'intitulé digne
d'un film d'horreur de ma thèse sommes
fractales de pulse études
dimensionnelles et multi fractales des
trajectoires et simulation à partir de
là vous allez travailler dans votre coin
rencontrer vos directeurs de temps à
autre j'ai connu des thésards qui avait
des rendez vous hebdomadaires et
franchement je les plains parce que
quand tu as rien à dire tu te retrouves
devant eux comme un con c'est pour ça
que d'autres préfèrent déjà bien échangé
par mail car ça évite de perdre du temps
et assure un échange régulier mais ce
n'est pas tout vous allez devoir rédiger
une thèse et c'est long une thèse 3 à 6
ans selon ce qu'en pense aux directeurs
mais aussi les financements que vous
recevez car comme souvent l'argent est
le nerf de guerre pendant le doctorat
pour subvenir à leurs besoins beaucoup
choisissent donc de commencer à
enseigner on peut le faire à
l'université dans les cours de td c'est
pas super bien payé j'ai donc choisi
d'être prof de mathématiques au lycée
devoir s'occuper des classes du lycée
edouard branly de nogent-sur-marne la
journée élire la nuit une demi-tonne
d'articles imbitable pour le commun des
mortels c'est comme si vous aviez de job
à temps plein et des semaines de 70
heures et on commence à toucher aux
problèmes de la thèse tous les
doctorants vous le diront c'est un
moment traumatisant a nommé professeur
disait qu'un doctorant qui n'est pas en
dépression ne fera pas un bon docteur 25
% d'abandons en général et seulement 5%
en sciences et sont un sondage shooter
on voit que plus de 80% des thésards ont
déjà connu de très mauvais jour pourquoi
pas ce que vous allez devoir affronter
les deux plus grands cauchemars de la
thèse d'abord il y a la peur du cul de
sac imaginez vous travaillez sur un truc
pendant deux ans et vous rendez compte
que c'est faux tout ce que vous avez
essayé de prouver ne mènera à rien ça
arrive à beaucoup de désert et c'est
très difficile de rebondir et pivoter
une amie à moi c'était pris ce mur je
peux vous dire qu'elle a fini sous
antidépresseurs un mes meilleures amies
rédacteur sur la chaîne lui a carrément
abandonné sa thèse après avoir découvert
que ces recherches ne menait à rien et
que ses directeurs l'avait totalement
oublié pendant un an d'ailleurs deuxième
cauchemar choisir le mauvais directeur
de thèse ce gars sera votre qui lit
votre papa votre coach votre scène c'est
celui qui vous empêche de tomber dans la
folie et de désespoir je vous jure le
côté mental est primordial
alors si vous entendez pas avec lui vu
que vous pouvez très difficilement
changer ça va être compliqué pourtant
avec la pression la fatigue leur
pointillisme les classes sont presque
inévitables voyez moi je peux être très
chiant et mes directeurs ont été de
véritables tanka dégâts donc les clash
je les voyais plutôt comme une manière
de me secouer et de m'aider mais dans
d'autres cas j'ai vu des directeurs
insulté le travail de leurs étudiants ou
même le contraire avec une amie qui
avait dans son cas un directeur très
cool trop cool il l'a laissé totalement
faire en disant oui à tout sans jamais
la faire avancer durant deux ans des
pressions elle est partie enseigner dans
le secondaire une fois les trois ans de
thèse minimum terminer vous pouvez
entrer dans la phase de correction mais
attention ce n'est pas là vous êtes
noter c'est comme si votre prof du lycée
corriger votre copie vous rendez votre
feuille en vous disant quoi changer pour
avoir 20 sur 20 et recommencer jusqu'à
ce que la copie lui paraissent
impeccable ça paraît délirant mais à bac
+ 8 vous êtes des jeunes adultes et un
professeur vous n'allez plus à prouver
votre sérieux l'idée derrière une thèse
c'est pas de vous sanctionner par une
mais de cris du savoir donc des dizaines
de chercheurs vont re lire vos travaux
et vous aider jusqu'à ce que ça soit
parfait ça rigole pas septembre 2021 à
un mois de rendre ma thèse on m'a collé
des milliers de correction pour
seulement 150 pages j'ai tout corrigé
avec quelques nuits blanches au passage
une fois que les rapporteurs juge ou
votre manuscrit valide vous passez à
l'étape finale passer devant l'ultime
jury qui peut en un revers de main tout
balayé à la poubelle un travail de
plusieurs années juge et ça fait
toujours quelque chose des personnes qui
ont le droit de vie ou de mort sur votre
carrière j'ai eu la chance de tomber sur
de très bons rapporteur mais j'imagine
pour d'autres vous êtes donc parti pour
la soutenance de thèse devant un
parterre d'experts un public et votre
petite maman pas de stress normalement
si vous êtes là les relecteurs ont fait
leur job et la thèse est déjà dans la
poche les mêmes admis de commencer à
installer le champagne et les petits
fours dans lequel vos rapporteurs
piocheront pour fêter votre titre de
docteur ah ah mais ça arrive que ça ne
se déroule pas comme prévu imagine tu te
fait recaler et en plus il doit servir
le champagne à ceux qui t'ont anéanti
non je vous rassure il désamorce la
situation avant que ça n'arrive sinon
vous serez pas en train de soutenir
vient le moment où solennellement où
vous remet le titre de docteur une belle
et longue étape qui touche à sa fin
n'est ce pas tu as passé le dernier dan
il n'y a plus rien au dessus tu n'as
plus qu'à passer le reste de ta vie à
contempler le reste de l'humanité d'un
regard méprisant pas du tout ce n'est
que le début d'une longue aventure il
faut maintenant trouver un poste
d'enseignant chercheur à l'université et
croyez moi la sélection est très rude
mais ça on en reparlera dans une autre
vidéo à quel point faut-il être doué en
mathématiques pour devenir chercheur la
réponse va vous étonner mais pas tant
que ça être bon en mathématiques ça ne
demande qu'une seule technique secrète
et ancestrale que je vais aujourd'hui
vous dévoiler le travail
quoi je rigole par regarder mes
bulletins au collège ou même en seconde
j'étais une brêle les maths ne me sont
pas innés mon cerveau n'est pas un super
calculateur béni des dieux mais un peu
par hasard j'ai fini par prendre goût à
la matière des profs qui m'ont inspiré
des problèmes qui m'ont questionné et au
final une seule et unique obsession
comprendre paradoxalement ça le plus
souvent failli me décourager ça n'a pas
été d équation à deux inconnues ou les
calculs de la place ya encore donné
cylindrique mais plutôt ses petites
voire rempli de préjugés qui me disaient
de changer est-ce que je suis à la
hauteur il n'y a aucun déboucha par prof
mes parents veulent que je devienne
ingénieurs avoué on les a tous et
pourtant on sait à quel point elle
fausse notre jugement ne choisissez
jamais votre parcours pour être avec
plein de filles ou avec vos potes votre
vie sociale ne restera pas l'école tout
doute revit le monde extérieur et bien
qu'on passe et riche pour les parcours
qui font plaisir aux parents comme
ingénieur médecin ou avocat oui la
daronne sera fier de vous présenter à la
communion du petit cousin mais elle le
sera encore plus si vous êtes vraiment
heureux et pour les débouchés regardez
tous les masters qui existent en
mathématiques à chaque fois c'est en
fait des métiers très concrets qu'il ya
derrière et c'est pareil pour plein
d'autres études de la philosophie à
l'économie et si jamais on s'aperçoit en
cours de chemin qu'ont fait fausse route
il est toujours possible de se
réorienter combien de vos youtuber
préférés sont surdiplômés et qui n'ont
pourtant pas du tout la vie qui leur
étaient destinés comme l'argent ne fait
pas le bonheur les études ne définissent
pas tout dit mais si on va se l'avouer
ça aide beaucoup c'est pour ça qu'il
faut être curieux entre vos 7 et 18 ans
et youtube est une plateforme parfaite
pour ça là des chaînes de boulanger de
conducteurs de grues de mathématiciens
laissez vous inspirer ce monde est riche
il suffit juste d'être à l'écouté
[Musique]